what it didn't sound like you were gonna
do it properly you're listening to the
dollop on the all things comedy network
this
is a weekly
american history broadcast
sir we're each week i
week is not in this enough dave anthony
read a story nobody called this a week
intro
to your husband gareth reynolds who has
no idea what the topic is going to be
about that's right ladies and gentlemen
we've fused history and comedy here at
the dolphins
coming back after a quick message from
coca-cola there's absolutely no way
anybody knew it did not already turn it
off
first time listener to this podcast i
think it's important that we make it
really clear they
was that clear or was that just
disappointing somebody took comedy and
somebody took history and somebody put a
penis in something and finished and they
had a baby this is the dollop
there you go
all right what are we going to do
what's next no what dates
hold on come on man time is money i
don't have a lot of time today no mime
is money
um what a dumb thing what'd you say what
did you say i'll tell you i will tell
you ladies and gentlemen imagine history
and comedy running into each other at
full speed and smooshing
okay so this is imagine if paulie d was
history and snooki was comedy they're in
the smushroom this is the dollop god
damn it on an all-new dollop
j uh this jet this thursday we will be
doing a live online dollop
virtual virtual on moment house december
16th 6 p.m pacific go to momenthouse.com
the
dollop and then um
we got a bunch of shows coming up uh
i'm just i'm not going to name the
cities why
i'm not going to hate dates i'm not
going to name dates you don't like the
towns
we are going to be in boston new york
city washington dc philadelphia
madison
uh milwaukee milwaukee
chicago
st paul which is right next to uh the
other big
they're called twin cities so you can do
either one and then seattle and portland
uh those uh tickets are now on sale
those dates start in may and they go
through june and then we'll be adding
other ones so people are like why don't
you do my city and it's like
just hold on and then of course the best
comment when you say hey i'm going to be
here someone goes what are you coming
here
uh we'll be in australia in april perth
adelaide uh melbourne
uh brisbane
sydney canberra
and sydney again um and then i'm sorry
we had to uh drop uh new zealand off but
that's all my fault you don't blame
gareth play me
dave's an [ __ ] and that's why there's
no new zealand okay but we will get
there we are very sorry dave i also will
be in indianapolis this friday december
17th at the white rabbit then saturday
december 18th i will be at the tiger
room then sunday december 19th i will be
in somerville massachusetts at the
crystal ballroom did i mention that was
fort wayne the tiger room i hope i did
uh then i will be in kansas city
december 30th through january 1st and
then i will be in uh
west jordan utah uh at wise guys uh
january 21st through the 22nd
garethreynolds.com for tickets and
pickets which are actually pictures of
me holding tickets i'm selling those too
this is the comedy part of the hybrid
that is the dollop
today we peel back the curtain aaron of
all the podcasts you record would you
rank this in the bottom
today for sure
well that's
honest all right nice yeah i could have
been a it could have been a ruder answer
which i'm into thank you aaron very nice
viewer
um yeah but jo we should say again join
us this thursday you've got a lot of
tricks up your sleeve i read online so
momenthouse.com
the dollop
and i can tell you it'll be an
australian american crossover episode
you know it's weird because if you think
about it this podcast is kind of like a
crossover some say between history and
comedy and it's sort of like they
banged in this mushroom and then they
had a little baby
all right i'm so i'm thankful that um
guns aren't legal in our country because
i would have blown my brains
out a horrendous
thing to say
might have been fun
november 2nd 8th you played the intro 83
what did you play the intro song you're
going to do that in post yeah i'll do
them post such a i love this peeling
back the curtain go ahead
november 2nd 1883
year of our lord
jesus christ or as he's known in spanish
hey zeus hey zucchristo come on buddy
come on
jesse harriet danielle was born in
palestine texas
wow a palestine
yeah get i understand why they got rid
of it i'm sure they've talked about
changing that name i'm sure yeah this
can't still be there is this is a female
human this is a female human okay
her mother was a laura marie leonard and
her father james malcolm daniel sure
james is a railroad worker do we need
middle names i don't know i think they
did angle they just put them in a lot
back then but do we even need them now i
mean i guess you need it now a little
bit i mean you have a number you need
them i think now because when you go to
search a little much you gonna search
for someone online a little much i
already don't like the premise i don't
like you searching for people you know i
don't i don't like it gareth walker
reynolds well i don't want that revealed
so he was a railroad worker originally
from buffalo new york he met laura in
1876 while working on the railroad in
camden indiana and then from what i
remember his train went in her tunnel
and then they had jesse
mail it in a little less
he eventually had an opportunity with
the i and gn railroad and she very
reluctantly followed him to texas okay
she was nervous to leave indiana she
didn't like palestine texas sure uh to
her it was quote swarming with unkept
railroad workers and filled with black
faces oh my god damn i was like oh i got
a joke and then you hit me with that
part i was like yeah i don't even want
to touch this anymore
god damn
she'll fit right in it yeah perfect just
slide right into that baby
most quotes are going to come from the
book revolt against chivalry by a
jacqueline downhall so all right unless
i say otherwise just stop it
when laura arrived
she explained the area this is how she
saw it quote rain rain and everything
awful wow so welcome to town wow hi how
are you have you seen our town slogan
rain rain and everything awful i mean
she probably hadn't been there too long
probably it was just raining when they
got there yeah it was yeah but that's a
you know that'll permanently paint
everything off does it always rain
everything as we knows we know about
that
well that's when you think of texas you
think it just rained rain rain yeah of
course yep absolutely yeah all that
water um when they first arrived they
lived in a hotel
uh then they moved out of the hotel and
into one end of a warehouse in the train
depot go back to that hotel it seems
like you had a better situation where
you're just
living like macaulay culkin and home
alone too lost in new york rather than
going to well this is our part of the
warehouse we just need a curtain over
it's what i call a baiting curtain
boy i'm glad we don't have that room in
that building we had before with what i
hated was the bed the bed was really
difficult to adjust may i say the shower
the shower was something that i will not
miss yes
all right everyone um put your head on
the slabs i'm going to sleep on this
crate now papa ah good night my dear
dream of a hotel room
uh so a decade before palestine was
i'm sure someone's going to say i'm
saying it wrong because texas changed
the name of the
it's palinstein
[Applause]
damn [ __ ]
the ticket before palestine was
dominated by the ku klux klan okay
reconstruction in the area had ended and
it was pretty much just a town for white
people
so she was like i don't want to go there
because of all the black faces but then
in reality it's just all white people
well but there were black people
it was split it was a as all the towns
were sure
a railroad and then everyone's the other
side sure sure um so in 1872 the
international and great northern
railroads was extended there pushing
palestine into the new industrial south
people even started referring it to as
the new palestine so there you go right
railroad jobs sure
new faces right
uh jesse was their third child okay her
arrival made things much harder on the
family by the time of her birth their
domestic life was becoming more and more
difficult while they do live in a
warehouse when did when did people start
realizing you can pull out
um is there is there a religious reason
or is it just that they were like well
not as fun
right but still if i i mean the way that
they're like oh man
another one
where do they keep coming from it's like
you could try to do something to you
know i mean you know that's not a
recommended way to not make babies it's
way better than going
you know you could get a condom back
then you could yeah so what's the deal
i don't know and when that are those
reusable
yeah i believe you wash them and put
them on the rack that's [ __ ] crazy to
see i'm gonna drive my rubbers
let me just leave them up there you
could back we're doing socks and jizz
rags today sorry carl
carl will you put out your condoms so we
can [ __ ] later
that's right all hanging on here we go i
got seven
i got seven do you never know starb's
coming bring in the condoms oh deary me
good lord
this one's not fully
oh well that's sorry i got up there oh
okay
that was me daddy i'm just i mean
imagine the comfort lewis is hanging up
his rubbers
look at that well they had a big night
boy oh boy
looks like you'll really use the [ __ ]
out of those lois
yes i did we had a big night last night
you certainly are far i got into the
math oh what
man
uh so
yeah so uh they had another kid
everything gets more harder
shortly after she was one of their dick
tupperwares yeah that's right shortly
after she was born they moved to overton
a tiny railroad crossing
northeast of palestine okay
and then they had a fourth child james
malcolm jr come on they like they like
no they don't they say they like the
[ __ ] yeah but again there's a way
there's negative measures you how you
pull out no but that's just again treat
it like a murphy bed pull it out god
made the penis so it wouldn't come out
when you not true
damn these spikes
uh
so um overton uh very poor area sure
tons of physical violence death and
disease great great place for a family
people didn't go back to our warehouse
corner
people were desperate and violent jesus
out of a handful of businesses in town
about 38 were saloons oh my god
that's vegas numbers that is vegas
numbers that's a fun town that's
everywhere is yeah yeah
people love to use their guns
violence against black people was most
common
the black and white towns were separated
by an abandoned brick kiln
buy a kiln abandoned brick kiln so it's
just like you're setting up soccer goals
in a yard you're like this count here's
the goal line and then yeah
on the other side is where that's
probably where the smoke went
uh it probably blew that way most of the
time so they're like so then they go
okay black people you live over there
near the kiln smoke this is a theory
yeah this is my theory because usually
the
the black people would have to live in
the worst part right so that would be
how big is this kiln i'm i'm guessing 17
stories you're telling me you're an 18th
i've never been outside oh my god i
thought you were the expert no i have no
idea i just live in books
[Laughter]
so uh
lynching reached a record high during
jesse's childhood one lynching in
particular stuck with her forever
because uh they said a black man was
hung and then his eyes were burned out
with hot irons oh my god
good lord
the barbarism yeah the barbarism is
crazy and we've all we reveal
if you've looked you've seen the
pictures of the celebrating lynchings
and yeah they're
terrific
additionally
epidemics of diphtheria smallpox and
typhoid fever uh
rampant regular waves of them coming
through the town great
jessie's mom worked uh laura my guess is
fauci was still around me yeah
fascism sorry vouching vouchism fascism
you know what i'm saying yes you know
what i'm saying yes
uh jesse's mom laura worked as a nurse
and assistant to the town's only doctor
so she's seen it all sure right okay she
would leave home for two or three days
at a time returning as jesse remembered
it quote dark around the eyes pale and
silent yeah just shaking yeah yeah i
mean so we talk about with hospital
workers now where you're just like
they're coming home like mother of god
how was your day
i saw everybody die
there there's a new unsolved mysteries
okay it's on netflix they made a new one
i've been watching that i'm gonna cry
during the whole thing
do you uh want caramel popcorn audibly
i can't get hosted by that other guy
it's a new guy now i can't feel it
there's two seasons i can't feel it all
right enough i asked how it was we're
good
oh they didn't find this guy either i'm
i'm dead
inside quiet please unsolved mysteries
okay
[Music]
uh yeah so she's not having a good time
sure um
this all made awareness it sounds like a
good childhood yeah yeah well as i said
it made the awareness of mortality a
normal thing for anybody growing up
there you know just there
babies are dying all the time
okay in texas not anymore jack
those are the old days now they're gonna
not a one away stick now they'll still
die just when they come out now
well hard work will be over what like
the lord said once they're in the park
fire number yep
once they're in the park that's the end
of it just got to get them out
just like pizzas in the arms of delivery
drivers once it leaves the shop not my
problem
get them going there we go
two by two
three by three not something i'm gonna
care about for long
that's not two by two
four by four i like babies i want some
more keep them coming keep them coming
we want all the kids
don't you worry
we're gonna rid you of laws that prevent
this each little baby gets a special
kiss
that's the new texas anthem do you read
that that's horrible it's good for part
of it part of it works it's not great
okay thank you
um so jesse had a sister
lulu her best friend died
they put her in lulu's dress and put her
in a room quote heavy and sickening with
odor
they put her in like her dead friend's
dress and we're like isn't that cool i
think her friend didn't have a nice
dress so they buried her in lulu's dress
or maybe they just put her in it for a
display and then they took it off her
and gave it back to lulu i don't know
people i don't want to i don't want any
more answers to the question
uh so
the daniels were outcasts in the town
the what the daniels
the dangles the dangles that's a better
name um so they're outcasts aside from
being yankees which is obviously a
problem it's texas
it was mostly however due to james
daniel's intellectual curiosity
during a time when everyone went to
church james was an aggressive
religious skeptic and identify it as a
non-believer ah it's like that video you
ever seen that video where the the like
the res the wrestling fan
is like in the bleachers and he's
talking to wrestlers and he's like it's
still real to me
and they're like it's cool it's cool man
it's kind of real still it's that it's
that's where you're just like may i
please still just have a veil in peace
isn't it weird that he like that he made
us all and that it seems like we have
pro enough questioning we're good
yeah so he's he's i mean i can imagine
he's probably the only atheist in the
town right that should be a tv show well
the atheist comes to town yeah like a
doctor quinn medicine woman but with a
guy was like do you really think he did
it didn't seem that of course he did
why wouldn't he he's got magic hands
stupid
um so james was self-educated he took
books very seriously there are always
books around in the house he attached
that's his problem yeah oh yeah that'll
get you in trouble that's dumb
he attached the hopes of the success of
his kids to his hopes of the future so
he's like very invested in you do well
and dad will be okay and then dad oh
that'll have hope that'll be okay if you
do well you don't do well daddy has no
hope do you understand he dies inside
life
everything that daddy desires lives on
your shoulders you will bring me joy
you're everything
screw this up
and dad will explode how could it go
wrong that'll explode dad will die of
tears
so both jessie and her sister lulu
soaked up uh their dad's intellectualism
and religious skepticism okay
jesse felt that lulu was the favorite
daughter okay
lulu was quote smart dainty with long
brown
curls long brown eyes and blue you're
gonna say almost she got long brown eyes
daddy they hurt her eyes go down below
her chin they're like the clocks in the
salvador dali picture my eyes are long
and brown papa just keep being pretty
like you are yeah you know her she's the
girl with those beautiful locks and
those eyes that go down to her knees
and long
blue hair long blue hair big brown leaky
eyes
uh
so a small dainty with long brown curls
and blue eyes if she was a little lady
okay in the eyes of her father she was
also according to jesse quote the only
brilliant one in the family you know
you're the only brilliant one in the
family
morning jesse
yeah that's tough well look at my little
smart angel and the three dummies
lulu stand here on the number one
position crate again there you are and
have your waffles and here's some gruel
for the rest of you losers oh lulu you
are so mighty
he doesn't believe in church but he's
like why would i go to somewhere to look
to a god when i have one out of my four
children and three dummies uh instead of
three wives been three losers now pick
up after lulu you losers
uh so jesse was second fiddle to lulu's
brains and beauty okay to top it off uh
dad was also very insensitive and
domineering
jesse said he never really seemed to see
her quote except as a splendid foil for
the beauty of his favorite childhood
thank god you're here it's like you're
the uh it's sort of like you're the
control group in an experiment you're
what happens with the nothing and that
it's good for scale to present this
beautiful object lulu you are so
perfect
well here comes my little angel oh god
oh i'm sorry
you're just so ugly i didn't uh realize
next to lulu there that you were you
seem like a wild animal you are just a
blank canvas and lulu is a michelangelo
oh my good lord look at her and then
next to you it's just it's
you're sick
you are so precious
uh so
she's feeling rejected by the way the
rest of that song is like the coco
cabana oh sure yeah
so she's feeling rejected uh by her own
family any reason why i don't have any
rationale there was
yeah
jesse tried hard to make friends in town
she befriended the daughter of a jewish
woman who ran a boarding house for
transients okay there's a lot of texas
issues right there yep
in palestine no less yeah jessie would
go to the boarding house to play with
the poor kids there and she became
friends with black and white kids and
they'd play together
equal regardless of their race gender
just everyone having a good time sure
all the pores sure right right
uh and she finds happiness there at the
boarding house but unfortunately
short-lived because her friend moved
away and once again
she was back to playing just in her
house with her siblings okay
if you can call lulu a child yes which
she isn't
lulu's a hundred and fifty
what inside
[Music]
jesse didn't understand jessie didn't
understand why her brother could do and
get away with things she couldn't
so at nine she was questioning why boys
made the laws that she had to comply to
but they didn't have to live up to the
same jessie hi i work for the
indoctrination board we'd like you to
come in this uh camp for a little while
you're gonna spend a summer here and
we're gonna
find a way to unlearn these questions in
your little head okay yeah someone has
given you the idea that thinking stuff
like that is okay yeah but the men made
the rules and the boys made the rules
and you need to follow them and this
camp will be a good way for you to learn
how to do that oh yeah
nope i don't getting a little lippy
i'm just supposed to ask a question i
don't like that no you're here to not do
that okay
questions are for thinking never
forgetting answers to
it's something you're going to learn
when you're in here
i don't yeah
i just do you like your stuff
yeah we'll burn it what
don't ask questions
get in here
okay great
are there any what it feels like again
it just feels so much like the start of
a question and i just know you wouldn't
do that
okay
we're gonna give you the tools to learn
to just accept realities
don't rock the boat
okay okay is there a lady supervisor
what the [ __ ] is coming out of your
mouth right now it feels like question
marks
okay yeah there you go that's the spirit
all right we got a new one
uh so
she withdrew into her
father's library
uh when when grover cleveland was
elected president in 1892 her father
gave her permission to stay up all night
to raise the flag in honor of the
election how long does it take to raise
a flag
put your back into it god damn it stay
up all night to raise a flag i read it
none of it made sense that's why i put
it in yeah what do you what
can i stay up all night to raise the
flag are you slurring the election of
grover cleveland
grover clear this is a big night for us
and again it just points to how little
was actually happening nothing nothing
was happening we'll stay up all night
and put the flag up and you're like oh
my god get me an advent calendar until
said day
it's so
it's such a crazy idea like
so she was gonna be telling your
grandkids about this night you
understand
the night the grover cleveland was
president and you got to raise the flag
you stayed up all night long all night
just holding that flag grover high
getting ready
got that natural cleveland buzz yeah did
you hear grover cleveland one holy [ __ ]
i just can't it's this is the saddest
thing we've heard yet i don't think
that's fair it's pretty sad that's not
fair
i mean maybe it was a simpler time and
that was better
i mean it you know
it was the new iphone
oh my god yeah that's right she talked
about it for years yeah and i got to
raise the [ __ ] oh you're gonna love this
story this is a real banger i stayed up
all day
grover cleveland had just been elected
you're not going to believe where this
goes i have a question yes why didn't
she just go to sleep and wake up early
and raise the flag
yeah
all right apparently this guy doesn't
remember the night grover cleveland got
elected sleep was not on the docket my
man okay it was a wild wild time
yeah it just seems like we were up for
about a week straight we put the flag up
and down it was nuts
oh my god i was
we still talk about it and once a year
we go out there and we put it up again
just to sort of relive it we wear the
same clothes we wore that night yeah
we've been doing that for a decade it
sounds awful i just i'm you know putting
it out there quite a night i'll tell you
a night to remember
it's it's not often when you go this is
the peak of my existence but that night
i was i looked at my wife and i said
this is it
it was
god i remember it so well
so when lulu graduated uh high school
her father took her on a trip to see the
chicago world's fair
just her and her dad
just to hurt her dad sure
another event that drove home who the
[ __ ]
lulu sorry he just took lulu not take
jesse she'll tell you what it was like
it'll be great pretty girl's going
somewhere wonderful
ugly girl stays home
brutal yeah brutal
so he's just you know clearly this is
the favorite uh
next he decided lulu needed to go away
to college so she's now 16
and he does not want her to just fall in
love and spend the rest of her life in
overton right
but he doesn't like the idea of being
away from his favorite daughter oh no
what is the angle here
so he decided we're both going to
college
i'm going to college with you lulu
it's fun daddy really loves you and he
thinks i'll just comb your hair during
classes
it'll be fine
so he decided to move the entire family
to georgetown texas where she was going
to go to school okay
so georgetown is 25 miles north of
austin and uh it's home to southwestern
university
move was good for the daniel family they
attended lectures and other events
there's a little more
intellectualism going on you sit in the
car and we'll strap the rest of the
family to the top like furniture
leo and charlie went to
the university
jesse attended the college's private
primary school sure
they now had the luxuries of being able
to get water from a hydrant instead of a
well oh man
they had 10 cans of milk in an ice chest
oh man well boobs are really a nice
chest for milk if you think about it and
meat options more extensive than fried
chicken because there was a market that
sold steak
so really a lot of things that you would
just assume were already things were
happening for them welcome to the city
you can have water and milk and ice
something that's not frying you could
put ice in a bucket instead of holding
it in your hands hold on now she's
fainting she's fading remember the most
exciting day was when we put the flag up
for cleveland until today
but uh georgetown
one of the most violent spots in texas
okay it's all that meat
uh brutal indian wars
and then there was the great fear which
in 1860 the great fear was a thing yeah
that's what it was called it culminated
1862 with
the quote largest mass lynching in u.s
history the illegal execution of 171
people in four counties
only
white people could label that the great
fear yeah right
yeah
it has a good pov that is relatable to
everyone involved
uh
yeah so
there was also
the glorified violence of retaliation
and uh that was associated with the
cattle industry you know all kinds of
stuff what do you mean it was like
fighting over land and right so everyone
is just i mean this violence is just
awful violence and violence and violence
right okay
james high expectations were a problem
lulu knew her dad was quote vicariously
starting college with her oh god it's
creepy as [ __ ]
ugh it's like if van wilder was your dad
so as much as jessie is like well this
[ __ ] sucks i'm the face
like lulu's like dad that sucks i'm a
favorite daughter i think he wants to
sleep with us
dan
we should do it babe lulu can i take out
your eyes and put them in my head here
we go
let's swap eyes he's just gonna like
single white female his daughter i was
thinking maybe i'll have your curls and
wear the same dress we're both lulus
does that sound good lulu i'm not
talking to myself can you call me lulu
too
yeah i mean this is clearly it's
is that where's the mother the mother is
still around they're still around here
so she's just like well all right okay
this is how you're gonna be her now good
joy
um yeah this is
it's emotional incest that's what this
is it's called jesus
term for it
uh
so it's like um
purity balls
yeah it's a little purity polish yeah um
yeah he's a baller purity baller baller
let's just go with baller sure it's the
same thing as on the hbo show absolutely
for lulu and charlie having their father
close did not work out neither could
live up to their father's high demands
you're not perfect charlie you lied to
me lulu dad i really just i'm just
trying to lie lulu when you said you
would be everything i ever wanted and
needed i had a picture in my head and
you did not live up to it your father
should leave class lulu
what about my dress professor is it nice
it's super strange what's happened
started off crazy and
now i look back at that as so normal i
have curly locks and blue eyes all right
not sure how to they didn't teach me
this i'm the best i'm the prettiest all
right i'm better than everybody here
okay this is um
you know we're trying to learn about uh
i know
okay
we're learning right i'm a big girl okay
this is my dad
um so
charlie got tired of the constant
thrashings he would get from james and
jesus so he's like you're perfect you
didn't do well i will be beaten
at the age of 15 uh halfway through his
freshman year he dropped out and ran
away to california 15.
so lu lulu graduated but she didn't get
great grades she didn't get high on hers
so
she was now a disappointment to james
i'm just you know i'm picturing like
when she comes home like um
well well well look who's not perfect
yeah i'm picturing uh
brando in apocalypse now like you said
you'd be that's right everything i
needed that's right dad is that you you
lied to me lulu you putting water on
your face
that's uh that's probably exactly right
uh so
lulu gets married and then just kind of
getting married
got very distant from the family very
quickly like okay okay i'll be over here
uh james was uh just beside himself just
without cheer without happiness sure no
joy left in james sure while his wife's
like okay
anyway i'm married to you and i'm here
and i'm your wife
there's no purpose to talking to anyone
i'm uh honey hi
uh so i've been married you for a while
you have i'm gonna put this cauldron on
my head and go lay in the yard for a
while okay
i hate my wife what no
so
uh jessie jumps at this opportunity she
can win over her father she's like this
is it
she enrolls in college at the age of 13.
everyone was doogie howser
due to what he saw as the failures of
his other two children jane james was
not enthusiastic about her college okay
great love at low bar
on the day she left for college she told
her quote young lady i am sending you to
college because there is nothing else to
do with you
rah-rah the first time you fail in your
classes you come out of school and go to
the kitchen oh my god i do not expect
you to graduate if your sister could not
handle the strain there is no reason to
believe that you will do so as well wow
so it's not even like on a level of i'm
not even that it was subtle before but
now it is i mean he's clearly just like
you will do worse lulu's way better
there's no way
you if you couldn't do as well as lulu
you can't it's impos
it's a literal impossibility to for you
to do what lulu has done which is not
good
you are all you've already failed at
college i would like a chance to go to a
class first i do understand that it
would be well that's how we're gonna
know
when you'll learn how to bake a pie okay
great because once you go into the class
two three months you'll be cooking in
the house because that's all you're good
for you're
not lulu right
okay well i'll go i'll go to college
i will fail at college say it no
say it with me i will fail at college
no for dad
say it i'll fail at college there you go
that's my girl you're not you're not as
good as lulu are you no
i i i
we're good i'm glad we didn't name you
lulu too
i'm far away from the house now stop
talking
can't go far enough
i smell failure
so jesse is determined to excel
this actually motivates her more mm-hmm
this great speech here
quote the goal was to beat my sister
so she's basically interesting family
dynamic he's created i mean it's like a
family of olympians yeah he's really
created a [ __ ] nightmare yeah yeah
but her college experience is very
restrictive
women at southwestern were segregated
into the ladies annex
the ladies annex it's just a annex it's
just they just have it's a section for
ladies sure so i'm sure it's less
everything's lesser sure right right
now these books don't have pages but
that's not going to stop us ladies
we will overcome that
it has more restrictions so between that
and her her father's strict rules
forbidding her from going to any
college social functions no parties no
nothing
and she has to wear her sister's old
clothes oh my god this clothes thing is
really weird
she was quote cut off from the
intimacies of girlhood and thrown back
upon books for companionship
so by the time her senior year rolls
around her father relaxes her
restrictions but but then it's too late
she already has like a complex
she
she was never at any event so she's
scared to go
she's totally freaked out by the dad
social aspect he's been a good dad yeah
yeah he's he's
he's really just set them up he's a good
dad for
totally great yeah
um
so she ends up with a reputation because
you wouldn't go to anything
so everyone thinks she hates boys
okay
so no
dudes pursue her at all everybody's just
like not that one okay
the only woman in her family who could
have been a role model model was her
father's half-sister
who had graduated from medical school
that had been started by a suffragist
and
she then became a member of the working
woman society
but after all that james thought she was
quote degraded and unsexed
after all what after
everything she had done oh my god
so that's why he's like he's like she's
not much
she'd gone to medical school and and
that was started by a suffragist and
then gone to do activism stuff so she
was just like oh my god but she's not
been banged all right
she's not been banged it's not worth it
but you wouldn't let anyone [ __ ] and
enough
he i like i as i read him i just get a
lot of my my uh alcoholism spidey senses
go off okay he's just got an alcoholic
vibe to him sure
or what we call uh back then a vibe
so upon uh graduating jesse was
considered a spinster
so you cannot win no you absolutely
cannot win right okay no you you you're
on the track
the normal woman track which is go to
school to look for a husband right
that's the only reason you would be
there right
and since she wasn't doing that then
everyone thought she was you know right
she believes her she thinks that she's
an old maid that says she's got i'm an
old maid at 19. okay i am washed up okay
am i an old maid
you yeah oh yeah i know you're i feel
that that resonates with me strongly
um so she moves him back with her she
moves back in with her dad
oh no yeah no and then cbs picked it up
for a season of inappropriate dad and
daughter
dead inside fish out of water
was miserable and disappointed in all of
his children why i mean because he like
created a horrible system no it's their
fault
how did i end up with four huge losers
well no one there's one there's one he
now still
the youngest one baby chuck uh jamie
he's got some he's got some hope for
james jamie jamie jamie jamie listen
said daddy jamie jamie jamie listen
everyone else in this family is [ __ ]
but huge hate me no jamie you you no you
with you you're the chosen one no dude
you're the reason i had three prior i
had to have three losers to know what a
winner smelled like jamie jamie jamie
jamie shut up jamie i like you daddy
loves you and you will fix everything
shh
shut up jamie it's shot up daddy like a
curse daddy needs you
to
uh
so
he hates that lulu
is married now and living in the same
town because he hates seeing quote
her love for another ranting around with
that
jesus christ you can't even make a joke
that's weirder
she's imagine being a dad being like
there she goes with that guy again
rubbing my face in it
we get it lulu you married someone who's
not your daddy
betrayal
[Music]
so
he decides to put in a transfer to
laredo which is a uh town i'm leaving
town my daughter's rubbing or loving my
face this is what people do when they
break up with something yeah they move
so lulu look i can't be around you
anymore obviously it's breaking up his
heart you're my dad i don't want to i
can't be around you anymore are you in
or are you out you have to pick your
husband or your dad husband
so they move there jessie loves laredo
she loves the weather the palm trees
mexican music also the latina women are
openly flirting with men like she loves
it all okay
and uh pretty soon she had a suitor
a friend of her father's he's an army
surgeon he's very handsome and he's 13
years older he's 13 years older okay i
assume very normal for the time yeah
that's actually maybe that's a little
too
too normal yeah absolutely young boy
didn't he yeah
shouldn't he be like 60. it should be
dying
she described him as quote an exotic man
of the world from new orleans
their romantic involvement was put on
hold though
because
jamie daniel got into a fight at a
baseball game and during the scuffle he
was hit with a baseball bat and killed
oh my god no the special one
oh no so now
now this isn't in here but this is my
thought
the only kid that he's put all of his
hopes in
dies young so he can always now go he
was going to be the best president we'd
ever had but then some time cop killed
my boy
he came here to stop him because jamie
would have united everyone in the
perfect way
he was the one the painting spoke of
the laredo
daily news headline quote cloud of
mourning prevails over the city yanks
lose by two
the paper said after he was struck with
the bat he staggered a few feet said
somebody help me and then claps face
down dying instantly oh god i hate that
i don't i don't want to be aware enough
to have that thought i want to
that's too much i want to i want if
that's me
oh you don't want to have i don't want
to be like hey i'm dying i want to be
like oh i'm dead
i would imagine there
somebody help me is just a terrible last
phrase to have
you know what i mean it's like just so
to be so desperate and yet have the
wherewithal to be like i need help and
yet it's probably so
such a common one oh damn it's probably
one of the most common ones stop i don't
like besides is that a clown
this clown hurt me
famous last words
that's what i'm saying that's why your
last words got to be crazy yeah yeah
before on the show
but you've just got to be like rainbow
sherbert come on hurry
yeah i agree
uh so yeah so
one attacker was charged with murder but
then not prosecuted so even you know
makes it even worse right right
with
the the the newest favorite child gone
james was quote out of his mind with
grief
he paced and got debilitating migraines
so laura slowly takes over the
responsibility of keeping the family
going meaning that she just treated all
the kids like [ __ ] how do i handle this
who's the best now uh i oh no i know
what to do you're all big losers
every one of you is a big disappointment
it's not it's like you don't do it like
it's like
lulu was great but then she married that
guy and i'm jealous it's like you don't
believe it like it's just like shut up
jamie you don't know shut up jesse you
don't know [ __ ] yeah your head's full of
what it's the matter it's a shame you
can't go have sex with your books
that would probably please you greatly
even though i do like this gentleman
you've been seeing
he seems right good for you no oops i
miss dad
well
shut up you stupid [ __ ] nobody cares
no
uh
[ __ ] you
um
yeah i don't know i do like you
something uh yeah you [ __ ]
you're worse than [ __ ] okay
if someone ate [ __ ] and [ __ ] that's you
get out of here i'm kicking out of the
house this is making me stay here it's
making me sadder
get some soup on the stove
you need supper
i'll get better no you won't
so
james leaves the railroad and starts
working at a phone company
good seems like the right time for him
to be working yeah
jesse resumed her relationship with the
army surgeon and then they got married
in 1905.
his name was roger post ames
sure yeah very normal middle name no
problem there
jesse was thrilled about uh the marriage
and for the first time she felt desired
okay
yeah cool upbringing
literally the first guy
wow love is great the first guy was
slightly nicer
amazing yeah
the newlyweds headed to uh pascagoula
mississippi where oh where are you
honeymooning
oh you're not even gonna believe it let
me mississippi do you like mosquitoes we
sure do
uh that's where the ames family had a
summer home now
roger's irish family immediately
disproved of jesse
not like okay did not like what's the
problem with her
well they saw her as uh socially
inferior to roger sure and they were
worried that she would threaten their
quality of life because they all
depended on roger for financial support
i feel very bad for jesse yeah it feels
like everywhere she turns there is just
people who want to make her feel
alienated and not yeah but she's also
unconsciously attracted to that right
it's you know we all are yeah
so
immediate just total hostility towards
her
so much so that they cut their honeymoon
short and uh moved to new orleans
wow yeah okay
when uh she went to a bank to try to
open up an account
she uh
was very upset to find out she could she
could not quote
um open an account the cashier looked at
me and asked if i had my husband's
permission
i hit the ceiling i said no it's my
money then i found out about laws
governing married women
so she was basically like it was better
to be a single woman
because i could have an account
now i can't have an account wow as a
married woman god damn always like
property with white dudes it's such a
[ __ ] up right well i own you now so
you can't do anything what about the
stuff i did before play in the yard i do
not think so not without not off leash
no your property now that's why we got
married i own you that is crazy yes
so throughout their courtship and
marriage their sex life was uh difficult
to non-existent
great good
roger warned jessie
that he had syphilis oh [ __ ]
when when do you bring that up in the
courtship well that would be a deal
breaker i can't bang well it feels like
well i can bang but your nose is gonna
fall off
it i'm really good at banging i don't
know if i'm lose nose forever good but
he later warned uh that he was impotent
he's syphilitic and impotent yeah is
that how [ __ ] that's a combo
yeah no that's good the odds of that are
when i did get it up i got a bad disease
the one time i got hard wouldn't you
know it i got the bye-bye nose
jesse thought this was all an attempt to
get her to bring off the engagement so
she hung in there
what again what is happening that's
another crazy angle he thinks i'm gonna
leave over his dead penis
but also she's afraid of intimacy so
this kind of works for her this is a
very strange relationship shortly after
they moved to new orleans a yellow fever
epidemic broke out and roger was ordered
to the jackson barracks to tend to the
sick in the military okay
and he sent jessie back to texas so this
is just a week after they arrived in
new orleans
so she felt like she'd been sent away
that
he thought he'd made a mistake and she'd
failed him i wonder where that feeling's
coming i don't know where she could
possibly come up with invents things her
being inadequate from this situation
yeah
despite all this in 1907 uh so they
still see each other uh they had a son
in 1907. so it did it did happen so they
had a syphilis bang that
but i don't know if he actually has
syphilis because it never comes up again
you know i could probably do one now it
does it's not inflamed
what are you
on weekends i'm i'm unsephilitic
i'm gonna [ __ ] you with john's penis
so it sounded like a wonderful
conception quote much against roger's
desire and wish
he knew
he knew he could not support a family
ashamed of the situation i forced the
issue i was desperate no i'm gonna
finish no no you will [ __ ] me
you will [ __ ] now
okay somehow so they have a beautiful
baby
ready to have two caring parents in a
normal house and somehow it does not
improve the marriage interesting babies
normally do that it gets worse texas
philosophy
uh roger is consumed by work and his
family
who
not only took up his time but most of
his income sure yeah he wasn't familiar
with the concept
really he's a lot of money oh no his
other his
oh all the people he's taken care of
okay the other aims the the irish people
who disapprove yes right
uh jesse believed they were trying to
quote blacken my reputation in letters
to him and then loose talk to everyone
so so the family's just [ __ ] trying
to take her down yeah right they're like
look at this hussy right monster
so they're they're they're a part most
mostly apart they're rarely together
great
um as jesse wrote quote this is the
picture of our married life i would
leave him somewhere new orleans porter
cortez puerto barrios
at the end of my rope i could not live
away from him i could not
live with him i always returned in hope
and job i was always sent away in
despair
i could do this marriage
that's how bad it is i could probably
pull this off
i just take him to vegas or new orleans
and then when i get pissed i come back
things came to head in 1910
roger's sister gave him an ultimatum
leave his wife and son or never return
to pascagoula to see his family again
i mean it's a little late down the line
isn't it what a crazy could you imagine
being like you have to leave your wife
and kid or kids the kid the kid part is
crazy people do that with like spouses i
feel like that happens yeah but yeah
with a kid to be like and you're done
being a dad to that kid that's it move
on
you made a mistake and the kid's like
two and a half now like it's not oh so
it's fine he's basically
no big deal they raise themselves
so roger had it and he responded by
leaving both his family and jesse i'll
show everyone
and he went to puerta barrios guatemala
and got a job as a doctor for the
american consul and united fruit company
okay so he's out that's it yep bye bye
yep okay
so now
so
jesse and her son frederick moved in
with lulu and her husband
okay who are very well off sure well
lulu's perfect yes well how could she
not be well you've seen her currently
she is brown
eyes right
um but uh
their their relationship isn't great
between the two sisters sure jesse
believes jessie believed lulu presented
a bad model for women quote a clinging
vine a parasite which was sustained by
love and patronage of men that's nice
that's a nice thing to say
it's my sister she's basically a love
parasite
so
anyway
her father was opposed to women's
suffrage and jesse's growing feminism so
james is just like
what's happening she's clearly right
has feminist ideas like what the [ __ ] is
i wonder why i want her i wonder why
what about uh the situation that she's
been around where you think would spread
i don't know
i don't know what would make her like
that father's constant need for control
over every dial of her existence oh
interesting
uh so
he tells her
he tells her to go stay with her husband
in guatemala even though she did not
like it there amazing to be like i'm
just sick of men telling me what to do i
don't feel like that's okay oh shut up
go to guatemala with your husband
i'm sorry i'm saying i'm revolting
against it don't be stupid
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] crazy men can't
tell women what to do go live with your
surgeon husband in guatemala who doesn't
like you and she hates guatemala so
uh quote stay with
your man and don't let the doctor know
for one minute but that you are having
the best time you've ever had oh my what
a [ __ ] i mean your daughter not only
will you go down there with him you will
act like you're [ __ ] loving it
daughter daughter look go pretend to be
happy in guatemala for your life
he's a man he can't take the idea of you
not being happy can you just [ __ ]
help him you're an actor in his play
do what i demand
[Laughter]
uh so
her father actually died in uh 1911.
and the cool thing is is that you know
his wife was did go to church right and
uh on his death bread he agreed to be
baptized all right
oh [ __ ] everything i believed in i
just let it go right now that's i'm
gonna pull that that's what they did to
my grandmother that's a great move at
the very end my born-again christian uh
uncle did that to my girlfriend all
right i'll go to his kingdom like just
yeah as a hail mary just so pisses me
off
they like when she was dying they mapped
yeah yeah they were like yeah she was
like okay and i was just like her whole
[ __ ] life she was like yeah
all right
it's it's a safety move it is if you do
get there and there is this white
bearded dude
well someone spent their life talking
[ __ ] didn't they
but i got it just under the wire dude
you barely did that's right yeah you hit
a three-pointer at the buzzer
i'm doug flutie
i mean again i don't mean but again it
is the absurdity of the idea
that you can i mean why go to church
your whole life if the option is on the
table for the last minute to just be
like ah yeah dunk me [ __ ] it 100 yeah
yeah dug me real quick i'll do heaven
sure [ __ ] it let's go
but i went to church every sunday and
wednesday and i would get on
paul i did everything i went to i had
everything like culminating
yeah and all he did was just get dunked
in water on his last day of life rules
and rules hey
what do you thought what did i tell you
i said if you if you acknowledge it at
the very end you're in you didn't have
to spend your whole life going to church
huh go come on in it's a party
everyone in here got dunked as a baby as
a dying senile old bag either way
i don't care
do i get a better seed it's the exact
same what the all your work i'm a priest
and i'm gonna be sitting here with this
lifelong heathen that's right if you say
at the very end you're on board boom
here you go
this is heaven
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh so
all right so the dad is uh
he's dead so she would she would go down
to guatemala frequently uh it's much
good to see roger as they're still
married sure um she tried to convince
him to return but he just yeah he
doesn't want to be around his family he
doesn't want to deal with any of this i
hate everyone
although frederic frederick was
unplanned and unwanted by roger
in 1912 she became pregnant again and
they had a daughter named mary
could i definitely throw another kid at
this problem i like how she's like i'll
create the exact same environment i grew
up in
in august of 1914 jessie had what she
described as the only quote happy and
contented time in her married life
roger seemed to have found peace with
his life and situation they had a very
very pleasant visit she returned home
pregnant with their third child
and then she found a house for them and
began planning uh reconciliation with
roger so she's like like he's playing
with him on board or sort of no with him
yeah like he whatever happened he like
came to peace with whatever the [ __ ] was
going on
um
yeah it seems good okay right so then uh
i went through this with my parents it's
not it's not well it didn't it wasn't
good anyways uh november 15th he died
from black water fever
black water fever
it's from uh black water
by the way now black water fever is
something different in this day and age
[Laughter]
i did look it up let me look up again i
think it's malaria um
it's a severe clinical syndrome
characterized by uh intravascular uh
whatever
uh renal failure wow it sounds really
good really bad uh it's some kind of
medically speaking your insides quit
yeah it's um
yeah it's a
rapid pulse high fever and chills
extreme crustacean and a rapidly
developing anemia
and the urine is black
oh there you go i'm out hey it's
licorice
i'm out
hey
jimmy obvious pissing licorice hey
i got the black squirts
uh it's i want to see my impression of
an oil geyser
it's one of the less common yet most
dangerous complications of malaria so
there you go okay
so basically died of malaria but there's
a better name because this sounds the
most horrible way to go yeah
well uh good news is everything's fine
bad news is you're pissing black my
urine is black yeah so
bad i would like to say goodbye bye
everyone
okay so he's dead
because of the tension between jessie
and rogers family she doesn't go to the
funeral and roger has a very big estate
but she only gets a thousand dollars
okay and she doesn't have the energy to
fight
for anymore okay so at the age of 31
she's a widow with three kids
so she's looking for what to do and uh
she's
she's always been sort of into serious
social issues you know that's yeah right
she was on that right um so she goes
into the women's suffrage movement okay
she joins up
um also the same time her mom had
inherited a phone company from james
james her mom inherited a phone company
it's like uhf
well phone companies are new and he had
bought
the company right before he got sick and
died okay
so and what if it's weird oh so i'm
buying a phone company all right good
night
what the [ __ ] did he say at the end
so uh
laura becomes a businesswoman with the
phone company okay and the local paper
described as quote a pioneer business
woman in a field of great corporations
and cold-blooded men okay so rare it's a
woman-owned business it's [ __ ] rare
right jessie saw her mother like her as
a victim of her dad right
um her mother had given her
like a fighting spirit and
unlike her father she supported jesse's
like rising political
she was like look i don't know what
you're doing but i know it's against
your dad and i love that let's go that's
great
uh so jessie jones up with her mother
she starts as a bookkeeper and then she
moves to manager on uh day-to-day
operations so she's you know becoming a
boss at the company also
um so it's two it's basically two
business-owning women
running okay at this time period
and they butt heads a lot
laura is still you can't do that
publicly though what did i tell you all
they do is argue these women
um laura the big thing they fight over
laura still goes to church jesse's like
not into church sure
um
laura worked in a nice secluded office
while jesse had to work
amongst all the telephone operators so
it's just a
it's definitely a hierarchy going on
sure
um
and then a lot of the male workers just
wouldn't respond
to having female bosses right so that
made it harder for it uh no
could you have a could you whisper to a
man and then he tells me what to do or
how does this work because you said it
right to my face and i'm confused
because you're a woman yeah so i don't
understand i'm not sure
you don't know how man woman works this
is not at all i'm pretty bad at this you
oh [ __ ] how do we do this because i have
to tell you what to do but you're a
woman to her
a woman to talk to her well i tell a
woman to you tell a woman to tell her to
tell a man to tell us what to do
oh i like that yes it's the game of
telephone
okay it should work great
so so they want you to use a man
to talk to them
she said she won't do that i don't want
to hear it from you jesus
she said she won't do so apparently she
won't do that tell that woman to tell
that other woman to tell us that through
a man
yeah i'm i think you don't work here
anymore so they don't think you work
here anymore yeah hmm all right well
we're fine good working for you sir been
a hell of an employment you're on a
tight ship my man you're a dude guys
guys guys
so
uh
you know
an angry customer storms in the office
one day
upset his phone a bit cut off for an
overdue bill
and he said to
jesse quote if you were a man i would
like to cuss you out
and jesse said quote now don't let that
stop you you just come right in here and
get it off your chest and then he just
quietly paid and left
i love that that that's like that is
i mean if you're trying to dissuade
women from working in a man's world
being like i'd berate you if you were
the other gender it's not like it's like
great good this is way better than
damn it
i'll pay the bill
so
yeah so there's two women running a
successful company jessie
realizes she's good at being assertive
and she
can organize and write the
administration stuff um
so
she's getting more and more into the
women's suburban movement and at the
time
there's a lot of pushback against women
voting if you can imagine
[Music]
even with other women
there's women that don't so it's kind of
a status thing in a way maybe well
there's you know i i mean a ton of this
is just class you know right
right right
jessie said most married women quote
didn't see any advantage of the vote
because they were taken care of and
working women kept their mouths shut
because they were worried about losing
their jobs what a
fertility environment for creative
people to feel secure yeah it's a really
good system that yeah yeah
so bring it at amazon that's right
uh the georgetown suffrage group relied
on their own resources to build support
jessie realized they needed outside help
and she sent pleas to the state
association headquarters and eventually
the men's suffrage league
uh helped we're fighting for men's
rights that's what makes me so i just
reading this and it was like oh we need
help oh yeah and then
that's
sorry they were a men's
men's suffrage league who no not not for
men yeah right okay they're fighting for
the women right right that's what i'm
saying it's just the idea i would just
love to see immense
men deserve the rights of women what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
men have been white men have been second
class white men listen we're sick we
want uh
[ __ ] what do we want we have everything
i don't know we haven't been great for
uh
oh
we don't want any other organizations
yeah yeah we did it
so on february 22nd 1970 1917 the two
groups co-sponsored georgetown's first
public meeting on women's suffrage
state president emini fisher cunningham
was the featured speaker and then she
became a mentor to jesse and pushed her
to start a column in the local paper
which jessie started
women's suffrage notes in the williamson
county sun so she's starting to you know
bring him a voice right
in may 1917 jesse was a featured speaker
at the equal suffrage association
conference in waco and she was elected
treasurer of the association
so she's a very vocal political activist
and figure in the movement
um anti-suffragist circulated her
so the people against women voting
circulated a family portrait of her
reading to her three kids oh my dave say
no more i don't even need to know what
it's saying it's a disgusting image
disgusting i had the idea
ah
those poor kids is it too late to get
those thoughts out of their brains that
she put in there
because they were pointing out that only
quote old maids unhappy married women
and childless married women wanted the
vote
what
so they're like there's no man in this
picture
so
obviously
these broken people want the vote
it's again they're they are good at
fight like you know like they can find
the thing they're like rock climbers
where you're like oh there's nothing to
grab onto and then like wait wait wait
wait
i think i could kind of pull myself up a
little bit with it like
they're caught i mean they're just like
on the fly just like she wants it
because there's no man she's a broken do
we want broken souls voting i don't
think we do
yeah because it's easier to come up with
like evil
stuff than it is
yeah positive yes yeah and it's it's
advantageous to be the people who can
always pivot yeah you know uh on
june in 1919 texas ratified the 19th
amendment which prohibits states from
denying the right to vote based on sex
not color
why ladies in october of 1919 jesse
founded the texas league of women voters
and was elected the first president
uh in the final months of winning back
the right
to vote of winning the right to vote for
women the right lashed back if you can
imagine sure
um there's also a
nationwide labor action going on and
then there are uh
black
groups forming to like you know so the
right is seeing this as sort of a yeah
there's a lot going on that they're very
upset about right
and the red summer resulted which we've
talked about here which is like riots
and murder and um
black people being attacked everywhere
again the name is really could be a lot
worse we chose
texas senator uh bailey then started a
campaign for governor that was simply
about attacking black people labor and
women's suffrage
still pretty good pretty good pretty
good it's like platform it's a good
platform yeah what's your platform no
blacks women
more white people stuff
damn workers [ __ ] them
two suffragettes uh were elected to a
damn resolution committee which bayley
called quote
a conclave of six sissies and two
sisters
good stuff
[Music]
and not that much different than today
no
really not no still dealing with voting
issues in major major ways
bailey's campaign manager warned the
women to be ready for quote stretchers
where the occasion will demand them i'm
sorry i'm going to go ahead and call
that a violent threat what are you
talking about well stretchers maybe he's
saying they'll get ill from the bad food
i'm talking about pants
stretchy pants so you're saying that's
crazy that they're going to get beat
yeah yeah in the streets cool yeah yeah
what a cool
yeah i guess you're right why would they
fight for something yeah it's really it
seems like things are fine yeah
bailey was defeated in the primary and
uh jesse became a delegate for the dnc
soon bayley was out of state politics
altogether
women won the right to vote and over 26
million women voted in the 1920
presidential election so
she's had this goal for a long time ever
since she raised that flag overnight
that's right
she's been a leader for a long time so
she's like what do i do next well there
was something that from her childhood
that's garter
and she set her sights on
that lynching
okay so in 1924b she became the director
of the texas branch of the commission on
interracial cooperation
so she wants to end the myth that white
women need protection from black men
right okay
it's all
i mean it's it's
getting into lynching and what it
actually is and the societal stuff it's
all very common but the basic idea being
you know black men are getting lynched
because they're being
protected well demonized and and this
mythology about their sexuality and all
this [ __ ] and then women by being
they're almost like a token in this
thing right it's like
well obviously some women you know call
the blow the whistle and stuff but
um
it's almost like well they're just an
object off to the side that needs to be
protected right because they're a lot if
you if you were so a lot of people
are now
sexually attacked by a black man
then well your life's not going to get
better there's the town's still going to
treat you like [ __ ] [ __ ] like a lot
of the rationale is like based around
like they like
black men are coming for white women
essentially yeah and they're so they're
able to operate that as like a
preventative move in a way or even a
reactionary move i forget what's his
name who uh yeah well there's tons of
stories of that where it's like
they're you know it's one little thing
but it is like yeah it's protective of
you hurt a white woman's feelings and
they're like i'm not necessarily yeah
but they're also terrified and then the
white woman is essentially
almost like an object yeah she has an
object in that scenario and it's just
it's just about
she's talking about pulling that thread
yeah she wants to she wants to unravel
the whole [ __ ] thing paradigm right
um which is fascinating because that's
like this is going to be complicated and
hard to do right
um
so
she uh in 1929 she became the director
of the cic women's committee
but
you know it doesn't pay well she still
has to have a job so they end up selling
the phone company to
to uh have money okay in 1930 she
founded the association of southern
women for prevention of lynching the
aswpl
it's committed to finding the main
reason that lynchings happened and to
prevent them
so big spoiler they they found racism
was a big cause shocking yeah very yeah
unbelievable right i always thought it
was just justice but yeah right amazing
um they also like i said they believe
it's profoundly harmful to white women
so they set about swaying public opinion
and appealed to white women
so they realize like okay so we have
because white women are also
sort of a
a victim in this
that
you can if we could appeal to them
handle it towards them and through that
and then we can right
change it right right right yeah right
which is a
fascinating yeah angle well it all i
mean
yeah because they're like changing
people's minds rationally will take
forever what we're going to do is make
them think that right yeah and then you
don't have to go directly at racism
right
um so
they start talking to they just start
hitting the streets
and they're going on and talking to
people and the writing articles but it's
it's a messaging campaign right
and you know they do this over years but
they end up getting 40 000
signatures
of southern women to end lynching
and
of course the petition drive there's
threats
and
yeah you know i mean honestly if you
were to be like
if we had to pick a race and gender to
start hanging from threats
who do you think it would be like
obviously you'd be like hey white guys
be like no no not us
right but so they're constantly trying
to undercut it because
yeah white white white and you know they
get letters and one guy wrote quote you
may have yourself a black if you want
one but do not force them on others if
you want a negro man okay otherwise lay
off white supremacy even then it's like
no dude that's the thought process we're
trying to get rid like it's like
obviously you want to have sex with
black man you know
well jesse said quote i have always been
curious about the white mentality which
assumes that only segregation and the
law against inner marriage keep white
women from preferring the arms of a
negro man i mean
like everything else just this like
paranoia i mean i again i don't know
why why white people are so in fear of
things getting taken away from them it's
like that's not what's happened where
this fear fear comes from as far as like
you know i mean
they just be able they just want to be
able to be racist and yeah say the same
[ __ ] they've always said right and not
be until the end of time and just
do everything yeah the crt thing is like
oh you don't want to just you just don't
want anybody to know the truth yeah i
mean to me crt comes down to this
parents who say the n-word in their
house
don't want their kids learning that
they're bad
even beyond that i think there is this
theory that
it is that the level of white guilt will
crush a generation of white people
and it's just like
so be like at some point you have to
reconcile reality you can't keep saying
happy thanksgiving every [ __ ] year
like at some point you have to be like
hey look
this whole thing's [ __ ] it's all
[ __ ] it's totally [ __ ] there was
no great dinner but they don't they
don't wanna i know because people are
like but the yams and the cranberries
yeah yeah
grandma likes thanks
you've built everything up on lies yeah
and then you're like yeah
but st why not why not when you do the
santa reveal also do the thanksgiving
reveal
yeah you're sitting your kid down you're
like look this dude he comes in the
chimney it's [ __ ] also the big
dinner we have around the end of
november it's actually so finn you
already got that like that's i'm sure
but i mean you should do the reveal like
there's no tooth fairy they're not
leaving quarters under your pillows also
thanksgiving was based upon us taking
land and taking resources from and
killing he still believes in the tooth
fairy
well good
um so it took a while but in 1936 the
public no longer accepted lynchings 81
state regional and national
organizations endorsed the
aswpl anti-lynching platform
and in 1940 for the first time in the
state's history no lynchings were
recorded in texas wow
so they kind of changed they kind of
changed she changed
i mean essentially was her like she
pushed
i mean there were there's obviously
other anti-lynching groups but she she
went after this mindset that wasn't no
you got white women going after yeah
yeah if you i mean i'm sure there's yeah
there's lots of work being done towards
ending lynchings but like did a huge
slice of that pie was convincing
white women that it was wrong yeah yeah
so jesse left texas to retire in north
carolina but she returned to texas in
1968 to live with her younger daughter
lulu daniel ames oh wow jesse died in a
moment he'll be perfect
you're the best daughter in the family
little lulu you're better than all your
siblings lulu
you're gonna come with mommy lulu
you live in my shirt pocket uh so jesse
died at pneumonia in austin on february
21st 1972 lulu quote she never let
anyone get close to her and when they
seemed to be getting close that was when
she broke it off or she put the veneer
on thicker the shell
because of the time and place she grew
up
jesse always connected epidemics that
killed many and the spread
of mob violence
um sources for this what a great last
line you prick
sources for this uh first of all ron
placone did the research and wrote it up
jesse
daniel ames the changing character of
lynching
and
jacqueline dowdhall revolt against
chivalry
jesse daniel ames and the women's
campaign against lynching
britannica.com
southwestern
uh
university
yeah that's it
uh
well i mean yeah that uh it's the idea
that she dies with a shell around her in
a way makes total sense because of her
[ __ ] [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah i mean
that's just gonna happen you have to
protect yourself and the the way to
protect yourself is to just cut people
loose as soon as you can like that's
just don't let people get close yeah
that's my philosophy yeah yeah no that's
why you don't even know my middle name's
walker
oh
yeah you [ __ ] that up big time um now
we're married oh good that's how it
works uh
yeah i
i it just is amazing the way that every
issue we have seems to just be
constantly pendulu like i mean it is
just
it's constantly in fluctuation and i
mean you do realize through like this
show that
you know the second that you have
a win or rights
they are immediately coming to take them
away
and so it's when you get
complacent and rest on your laurels of
these rights that you start to go holy
holy [ __ ]
abortion's going to be illegal yeah you
know
and we're living in that time in many
ways where the we've peaked as far as
the rights that we've had when it comes
to protests and all these things they've
learned they've learned ways to stop the
movements yeah and
it's peaking now with with the protest i
mean protesting is becoming an illegal
act
yeah i mean yeah there's tons of stuff
so how are we they're this is what
they're saying how the [ __ ] are they
gonna change things when they're afraid
to go to the streets and probably yeah
that's right that's they know whereas
you have not that it's a luxury but in
the previous times you know you you
could yeah the system would wilt
under the will
but when you silence the will or you
silence the whistleblowers or you
silence the megaphones these people
uh who would be there normally to start
revolutions when you get rid of their
voices you are like
it does feel aimless and mindless and
and you do need to remember that it's
calculated it's not that like
people aren't pissed and people don't
want they just don't see the example in
front of them right on how to do it you
don't see the example of how to make
change anymore i mean one of the biggest
revolutions that took place in my
lifetime was when they've got burger
king chicken fries
that was like when i was like this is a
goddamn movement but you know you have
those less and less now
yeah no that's absolutely right
so i did good you're a bummer um we
should also mention that soon on patreon
we have a few things we actually put up
their uh commentary on the which one was
it the falcon and the snowman falcon and
the snowman we did uh commentary so if
you want to watch the falcon and the
snowman with our commentary that's up on
patreon uh we also
um are going to start doing the quizzes
where uh dave will start giving me
dollop quizzes on patreon and we'll see
how i do on those
um um there'll be some small ups up uh
up there some small episodes
yeah we're putting more patreon there's
also we should point out that on patreon
for a dollar you can have an ad free
experience
and um
yes
you want that and you might want that
because uh
you know we've had a different couple
years with the podcast since the
pandemic so there might be an ad popping
up in the middle of the show which i'm
sure people will uh not be happy about
but again for a dollar go the patreon
route and then you don't even you won't
even notice so um and then are we doing
another oh the san diego one will go up
next week right uh san diego or vegas
yeah san diego based so yeah so uh so
this is our last episode of this year
then right or no
i think
who gives a [ __ ] it doesn't matter
anyway we would just you know to
everyone even if if it isn't the last
episode this you know
it's a weird time it is yes it's a very
strange time continue to hang in there
and um and yeah like dave said we're on
tour and all that stuff so come see us
yep we love you
i love you i'm looking at me i love me
you